oh hey you're not Batman I'm Batman I'm
Batman I'm [ __ ] Batman
no I'm [ __ ] with it I'll [ __ ] you up
love me oh hey hey you take me to your
leader
I could all right do you want to die
stay out of this but you have to learn
the way on your own worlds and I just
search not go hey hey hey put that away
that would not teach you the way that
will not teach me the way okay open
portal for me please
I need that like beautiful you sound
like a lush full of [ __ ] alright maybe I
need to search for you God there it is
Uganda has four other people in it
you [ __ ] kidding me they need to fix
this [ __ ] menu it's awful
oh wow it's I found the knuckles
everybody the skin of the what happened
the [ __ ] happened wow what a great place
skin of the devil hey hello fellow
Ugandan great communicating with you
can you this show us the way
okay but you have to go to the volcano
wait up please yes your face oh my god
oh yeah why are beaut I'm not go on
raise your knuckles that's right
born and raised from Uganda 2017 2017
but we re into 2018 in con I was by
right [ __ ] [ __ ] they discovered me [ __ ]
oh hey where is everyone hype Rhys
it says there's 400 people on this
island where is everyone I don't know
Queen
show us yes so what's the way but that
that's not not Cossack sonic that it's
doubloon this is my way that's Sonny
because my hello everyone your queen Hey
stop spitting on me hello everyone it's
your queen I have finally returned
that's the prophecy foretold that's
right
I am Amy Winehouse the queen of knuckles
you are welcome back straight back
goddammit
that's the most annoying [ __ ] place
I've ever been to
that was crazy
are you my father please accept me
brother
let's go follow me cutie pie can you buy
me some robots I'm poor okay you've all
been sold okay I'm not pretty actually I
know
thank you thank you thank you I feel
like I should stop